mexican president andres manuel lopez
obrador has urged crews to intensify
their efforts to rescue 10 miners
trapped underground
families are waiting on the surface for
good news that hasn't come yet
the president thanked the workers and
asked them to redouble their efforts to
be able to find the miners alive we
stress that time is short and that we
need to do what is necessary
for more than four days rescue workers
have been trying to pump water out of
the coal mine which flooded on wednesday
five miners were able to escape but no
contact has been made with the men left
behind
more than 300 soldiers and other
personnel including six military scuba
divers have joined the effort
for those above ground the only thing to
do is pray
we trust in god's mercy and we believe
in miracles and these families have
faith prayer is the only thing that
strengthens us in these times of
distress
doctors are on standby in case of a
breakthrough trying to offer some
comfort to anxious families
in this situation our patients sometimes
don't need medication so much what they
often need is for you to come in tap
them on the shoulder and motivate them
to give them a bit of reassurance in the
midst of all the uncertainty they're
dealing with
a little bit of attention goes a long
way
mexico's main coal producing region has
seen a series of fatal mining accidents
over the years
the worst was in 2006 killing 65 people
only two of the bodies were retrieved
there is still a chance for these tin
miners but with every hour that passes
hopes of finding them alive are fading
leah harding al jazeera